Well,
the gap that the celebrity feels is that
the celebrity can reach millions of
people like that.
So the fact that they land a voice,
so they need to Africa,
it makes millions of people that
wouldn't even care about Africa.
Look towards what's going on in Africa.
I think,
you know,
there's,
um,
I think a celebrity prep period during
any form of charity is a great thing
because a celebrity don't really have to
do anything as much as you want to think
they do.
They're celebrities.
So they could actually just chill and
don't do nothing.
But the thing is,
but then there's those celebrities that
don't own the land.
They name,
they act on it.
Um,
and of course the bar is rose so high
for these celebrities.
People like Angelina Jolie.
Um,
she's,
she been to Haiti with me,
Brad Pitt.
I mean,
look what Brad's doing at New Orleans.
You know what I'm saying?
Real initiatives.
George Clooney,
like going to these places,
looking with their eyes and,
and,
and learning.
And then I'm bringing the information
back to the American people.
I think that's where the future is
headed.
[inaudible].